hey guys it's Charlie today we're going
to talk about a game of Thrones Gendry
theory that will blow your mind that
goes all the way back to the time of
Aegon the conquerer people who have been
to the set where they're filming right
now have said some really interesting
stuff and it just completely throws
Gendry theories up in the air but in the
most amazing way so just careful for
spoilers for everything this happened so
far we're gonna be talking about where
that rowboat lands and what he's gonna
be doing once he gets off how thirsty
you get don't drink seawater not to
drink seawater
walk for a full beer night and you'll
reach rooks rest you want to stop there
don't he'll find you why should I go
just keep the course on your left side
until you reach King's Landing you ever
been in a boat before huh you know how
to swim no don't fall out one when you
get to flea bottom have a bowl of brown
for me so for the past couple of years
since gander II road away from
Dragonstone at the end of season three
fans have been wondering when is Gendry
gonna come back is he still rowing it's
seat is completely lost
they've even asked george RR martin even
though kendrys story from the books has
been changed and that's actually a
really important idea for this theory
changing gendry's storyline from what it
is in the books because we know on the
TV show he was given heed Rick storm's
storyline from the books and that's what
that whole Melisandre Dragonstone
storyline was in the books he had all
those nice moments with Aria and just
stated the crossroads it became the
blacksmith I'm going to stay on and
Smith for the Brotherhood have you lost
your mind good new PI's wonderful Thanks
be my best
the good kidney pie is all about the
ingredients don't get me started on the
gravy very difficult to get right see a
lot of people give up on the gravy you
cannot give up on the gravy that was hot
pie at the end of the crossroads missed
that dude so much so that's where Gendry
stayed in the books but most fan
theories about Gendry going forward have
to do with his reunion with Arya Stark
they had so much chemistry it would be
such a shame to waste that these
theories focus more on Daenerys but
here's where it's going to blow your
mind so the stark characters as well as
Gendry have all been seen filming at a
location in Spain as reported by the
Watchers on the wall and a couple of the
people that have been camping the set
that looks like it's doubling for the
exterior of Dragonstone in already you
really hype about Daenerys stark
Dragonstone things but Gendry has been
seen there as well
wielding a giant Warhammer with a stag
on it so it's as if they're doing deep
cuts for Robert's rebellion like Gendry
will become his father like he was
during Robert's rebellion great warrior
smashing people with his hammer and he's
doing a lot of Horace Baratheon things
his ancestor who was a Targaryen bastard
who himself was kind of like the Jon
Snow of his family the only difference
is is that Jon Snow isn't Ned Stark son
or as Baratheon was rumored to be the
bastard of Aegon the conquerors father
so technically he was a glance
half-brother technically Jon Snow is not
the half-brother
of the other stark children just because
his mother was Lyanna stark his father
was Rhaegar Targaryen so now there are
two big mind-blowing theories one the
Gendry will get a similar storyline to
Robert during Robert's rebellion and
will ascend to the throne or two because
I think that Jon Snow has a stronger
claim to the throne than Gendry just
because of his lineage he will be picked
over again dree to eventually ascend the
throne but Gendry should you survive to
the end will retake storm's end which is
as of yet right now unoccupied I know a
lot of people are wondering what's going
to happen to storms end well if you
haven't read the history of a song of
and fire back during a con the
Conqueror's time Aegon was the one that
named house Baratheon and gave storms
end to orous Baratheon his half-brother
so Daenerys could give storms end to
Gendry in that way either way we are
doing deep cuts for Robert's rebellion
just in Gendry walking around smashing
people with his war hammer like Robert
did and - we are doing deep cuts for the
time of Aegon the conquerer because the
show has gone out of its way to draw a
lot of visual and metaphorical parallels
between Daenerys and Aegon the conquerer
they both had three dragons they had one
giant dragon but Aegon eventually got
married to both of his sisters to his
blood so I think the show will pick Jon
Snow eventually over any other suitor
that Daenerys could potentially marry
but that is all on the condition that
everyone survives to the end of the
series they could all wind up dying
horribly and then you wonder like what
would happen to Arya if Kendra were to
retake storm's end she doesn't really
have an interest in being a queen but
she does want to return home so let me
know in the comments if Kendra is going
to be fighting like Robert with the
Stark in the Targaryen armies what do
you think is going to happen to him if
he survives to the end do you think that
he will become a suitor for Daenerys or
do you think that like Horus Baratheon a
gods half-brother he will retake storm's
end I feel like the second scenario is
more likely but either way it completely
blows my mind goes way above and beyond
my expectations for Gendry so I cannot
wait to see what they do with the
character and for those of you asking
about Arya stuff like this is all
focusing on Daenerys but I do believe
that Arya and Andrey will be reunited as
part of this bigger Jon Snow Daenerys
alliance but I do feel like they're
trying to do everything they can on the
show to give Gendry some really awesome
moments that'll make the fans happy
who've been waiting this whole time to
see him come back so a relatively minor
character from the books gets to have
some really amazing moments so I think
that's the whole point and they just
want to do something really fun with the
character that everyone's going to like
even if it's a little bit different from
the books which I feel like even people
who are upset that the show has
changed the books will enjoy I served
men my entire life
I served master Mott at King's Landing
and he sold me to the watch I served
Lord Tywin at Harrenhal wondering every
day if I'd get tortured or killed and
done serving I've never had a family I
can be your family
[Music]
you wouldn't be my family
you'd be milady like Gendry is a
character with a lot of potential he
looks like Robert he's really good with
a hammer
he made a helm that was a stag so
wouldn't he eventually make a Warhammer
pick it up and start swinging it around
when it's time to start fighting White
Walkers but as for endgame it really all
depends on who survives and who ends up
dying
if Gendry can make it to the end if arya
can make it to the end i think it's more
likely that he would get like a far Emir
Lord of the Rings return to the king
type ending you see a o in of Rohan
standing there so I know everybody's
like ooh wait a minute are they gonna do
that with with him and Arya so you can
make all the predictions you want about
that because George are Martin said that
the ending is very Lord of the Rings
esque very bittersweet so you can draw
all the parallels you want but this
theory video is mostly just focused on
the immediate season 7 stuff that it
seems like might be happening but if
there are any other game of Thrones
Theory videos that you guys want me to
do just let me know in the comments in
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner bought so you win a $20 Amazon
gift card there is a new round that
starts now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video so it's a big weekend we
have Walking Dead starting tomorrow I'm
going to be doing videos for all the
episodes and there's a really crazy
Deadpool stuff that just happened that
I'll be doing a video for so that will
probably post next so change in the
outro just a little bit why you guys
wait for that next video to post you can
click up top to learn all about the
dragon pit and you can click down here
for the Walking Dead Season 7 Nikken
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight